I'm joined by a good friend of Nicholas
Emma White um good to see you again Emma
um we keep calling her Nicola you knew
her as Nikki yes
um and um your thoughts uh I'm
interested in your thoughts after that
update from police yesterday when you
heard what the police had to say what
went through your mind
let's just take you back to yesterday so
yesterday was a seven day Milestone it
was
um a roller coaster in itself you wake
up oh still no news okay we'd already
planned the seven days a big media
publicity we were out there with the
banners so then to hear just in the
afternoon that had driven awareness
influx of calls that hope was ignited I
couldn't tell you the feeling like
something's got to come of all this
information we then get
the News Bulletin
and it comes up with this hypothesis
then that sinking feel it again and I
just wanted to um to quote so what we're
saying is
um what struck a chord she said the
search continues to no avail and
obviously a hypothesis is unlimited
information and when we're talking about
a life we can't base it on a hypothesis
surely we need this factual evidence and
like you've just both said that's what
the family and us are all holding on to
that we're actually no further on than
sadly last Friday we still have no
evidence and that's why we're out again
in force
yeah I can sense frustration in your
voice do you feel frustrated
he's not frustrated but you don't Base
Life on a hypothesis do you absolutely
can have hypotheses but then
you need something to back that
hypothesis up to become factual
do you think it might almost have been
better not not to have mentioned that to
have just said we don't have any new
information but we are still appealing
for help we are still appeared like they
did dash cam footage and the like but
actually not necessarily saying that
that is now their Theory 100 and I think
we just said we talked to family they
obviously discussed that with the family
we didn't believe it was going to go
into a Live News Bulletin when it is
this hypothesis so
yeah yeah you're great friends with with
Nikki and Paul what's Paul saying
um this morning what did you have a
chance to speak to him after the
conference yesterday yeah as soon as we
heard we said what's the message and he
was
he was going keep going until we find
something factual and you were here
chatting to me yesterday and you were so
buoyed up and and so hopeful because the
police have had more calls haven't they
they had more information through did
you did you get any sense of what that
information might have been no I all I
know it was a significant influx and
calls that they had to bring another 101
team into want to answer the calls so
when you hear that news coming from the
police you think oh my there has to be a
glimmer there has to be something coming
from that today just to give an in a
line of inquiry to go on so when the
News Bulletin came I thought oh I might
have found something that we don't know
um and we thank everybody that did come
forward what I would say is we need to
keep it to factual information like they
could have received 100 calls on I don't
know that's not relevant to the case
yeah it needs to it needs to be a
genuine Factor information no that's a
good point
um there's been a lot of talk about a
tennis ball
um and that Willow love chasing a tennis
ball and perhaps the ball rolled down
this very steep Bank where we're
standing ended up in the water and Emma
um understandably tried to retrieve the
ball simple as that as you would do on
dog walk what do you think about that
theory uh Willow used to love a tennis
ball very much
um but it used to Disturbed the walk so
they haven't had a tennis ball
since way until last year obviously with
tennis balls she loved the tennis ball
so she'd always be by you pestering you
for the ball that it wasn't a nice walk
when the dog's pestering so the ball the
ball was no definitely no ball okay well
that's really interesting and as a dog
owner I know how annoying it can be
having dogs obsessing over balls so you
don't think there would have been a ball
okay
um and finally
um what is your message
today to people watching this who will
share your anguish they'll share the
family's anguish and their desperation
that perhaps things are narrowing down
now in terms of of getting Nikki back
what what's your message
again yesterday they said they haven't
explored all the Avenues and we've got a
footage missing from garstang road which
is just outside of the river the way you
come into the gate for the walk so we're
appealing again for anybody that has the
dash cam footage any information on that
then when we explored that Avenue then
hopefully the police can piece a bit
more of the pitch together I know people
will be coming out in the force a day
we've had message after message and we
thank you we've got Roots set up for
people to do today and we've actually
overnight
um got I think we've already shared it
we've got this eight ten foot
illuminated box that actually drove from
Blackpool to Preston last night it's
going to be driving around it's going to
be in prominently in St Michael's today
just to raise that awareness and if
someone can just shed a little bit of
light to give us some evidence
that's all we're asking and it's just a
simple phone call a simple phone call
and nothing's nothing's too small but
then again don't clog the lines with
trivia no no and for you you're not
ruling anything out not ruining anything
out no and we have to I've always said
my children Nicky children we've got to
carry that hope but until we find
something we can't we can't go and tell
them we have a hypothesis it's going to
be tough for the little girls this
weekend isn't it very very much so and
we've all been about the routine so
they're going to the clubs and doing
what we normally do on a on a Saturday
and just keeping them occupied